聊聊怎么卖东西怎么争到小钱
我又说怎么做到小钱
很多人说
这就是个韭菜的
这样
我没客说第一件事情
第二件事情的话就是我真正要讲的会已经在那条视频里了
你不需要第二步你三步 你知道的这个视频做
你的这个车工率会高很多
我为什么会想到这个概念呢 因为我突然就意识到
有些时候我们真的不知道该做什么
就是我想卖东西 我想做的小钱 我想自私齐力
我真的不知道该做什么
对吧
或者什么呢 就是
我也做了 你说让我去拍点视频让我心情文章我爱去写的但是我真的赚不到钱没有流量啊 对吧
这些问题都是真正存在的 所以呢我想
今天给大家另一个
这个框架就你照得做这个成功率可能可能就
更高一些 不是说你一定承课就成功率和更高一些
这个框架叫什么叫AID
就是我来四年前
我就专门讲过这个 直播里面讲的免费讲的
对不对 那好多人说这个
你就是讲这件事情 你去看我当年的直播连续讲的好几期我可以这么讲
你在外边交费的那个那个费用 可能就是上了课 可能都不如玩那个直播
更干货 那个
那个两个直播一个叫营销信号数 你们最差
今天给大家一个大概的框架对吧 就解药的框架
叫AID什么意思呢 A就是指出的
AID就是兴趣 第一是预望
然后最后这个AID就是行动 买单
那简单说一下
正好今天早上 我送我工程上学
哎 我就突然问了我一句话
说这个
爸爸为什么学乡蒙口这么多好吃的呀
哈哈 他妈妈就回答他说
做生意最重要的是什么 这是地段
我说妈妈说的是对的
但是呢
地段是最重要的运速之一
那么更自女的说法 叫什么的 叫劉亮
叫劉亮 对吧 比如说为什么
去这个大商场一样 因为有劉亮嘛 为什么就不清清呀
因为有劉亮嘛 对吧 我为什么去短视频平台呀
因为有劉亮嘛 对吧
所以有劉亮的方式就是你到处打 大家已经知道你
别人不知道你东一最好
有什么用呢 对吧 你看我们之前上个礼拜吧 我那个老伙就是
东成品是好产品
哎 介绍东西介绍的约很
也很好 也弄多大东呢
但是就是没劉亮啊 对吧 九箱也怕
像的什么 对吧
所以呢 这是第一个就是你要劉亮 你要让别人有兴趣
劉劉亮了
对吧 比如说不兴趣啊 爱国才开在这了
但是人家一打点就没欲望
一看就不敢兴趣
就不敢兴趣 对吧 那有什么用呢 对吧 所以你要让别人敢兴趣
然后这个时候切中了
用户的通点 比如说我特别 我想要什么 比如说
哎呀 我这个时候我腦了云争争争的
哎 你怎么能帮我建训了这个问题 对吧
或者是我想穿一件 特别漂亮的衣服 然后参加
基本上的约会 对吧
就是 我觉得我应该有这么一个东西
这个时候我会产生的行动买单
但是今天我想和大家重点看什么呢 就是我说我们很老伙
确实已经行动了 已经拍了 对吧 但是没有劉亮 所以我把重点放在前两个部分
一个就是你怎么产生劉亮 另外一个就是你怎么让用过感兴趣
啊 怎么产生劉亮呢 比如说我推荐大家就是最好是在一些
互联网平台上 为什么在互联网平台 为什么推荐大家
邪点什么 拍点什么 因为他们有什么成本
对吧 你开个电
对吧 你说我在这个地方这个地段好 开电那么在房租吗 你说摆东西呀
我推荐大家就是一开始 今天要使用这种没什么成本的
我浪费点失愿 现在现在我们的事情还不值钱 对吧
哈哈哈这个说起来召唤很不像我这个时间这么值钱
好 那么这个时候你发现拍视频啊 然后写文章啊 还是可以的 但是我们发现很多老伙企拍那个视频没图战
那么劉亮怎么办 终于你要注意两个部分
第一个部分就是你要切住人的需求 让人家感兴趣
对吧 第二个什么呢 你要切住AI的需求
所以你拍的那个视频啊 你是给了两个用户的 两个用户的
一类是用户真实的用户
一类是什么呢 一类是机器 就是算法啊
哈哈哈 那个算法来用什么来运放亏了
那好 首先第一个部分就是你拍那种的时候不要一上去说你的产品 没人对你一个东西感兴趣
人们想要的是更好的自己
所以在你写那种的时候拍视频的时候 你一定要想一个东西就是你的用户是谁
他有什么样的需求 他对什么
感兴趣 而不是你要卖什么 你要做的第一件事情 比如说你拍视频也好 请文章一号做的第一件事情
就是把它吸引进来看你的文章
就不只是说 拍视频现在才有的 你会发现其实之前就有了
写文章的第一要一开头的作用是什么
文章的第一句话的作用
就是让读者让观众看你的第二句话
哈哈哈你的第二句话 到作用什么
让文章让读者让观众看的第三句话
对不对 听懂了吗
所以有些时候一上来你要讲用户感兴趣的东西 不一定和你的产品有没有关系都不重要
然后呢 你然后后面怎么吸引呢 就是给用户的来讲是
还用户关感兴趣的
有些时候面对的产品是非常好的东西 给用户纠
纠受是个好东西 注意啊 这地方我再给大家做一个分析我们的垃圾来
就是卖东西最好的方法不是一上来都卖
是什么的这个给
教授
教授别人使用 教授别人一些知识
这个时候女会发现 你反而会建立全为更容易的全卖东西
这是一个分支 回过头来 我们先讲一开始你要把诱心再开头就怎么做
那很多时候我去打学呀 我上什么客压 我告诉你不要有这么想法 你就记住了 你不是来到这个星球上的第一个人
你语着到问题 百分之九十九都我答案
对吧 比如说一些唱消的书啊 一些好的电影啊 但开头都是可以值得你学的 就翻了
实在不凶你就找网恨的短视频 谁的流量大谁都不会放那么大
把他扔到人工智能里面给你拆一下 你说为什么这条视频不放那么大
他他开的时候怎么开头的 你照到这个开头看我的产品 你一帮我洗一个开头
何不可以啊 对吧 然后你今天写个文章 你拍一条视频
你试一试
那你拍完了 以后你喜欢了以后是不是就流量的不一定啊
对吧 就好像你第一次到处入过 就能到进去吗
对吧 你第一次 你第一次吃饭你就会吃吗呀 不是啊 我们还
有的时候你会发现有些地方大餐
你真不会是 你在看别人怎么怎么 怎么吃的你才会吃
你第二次才会是不是 这都是经验 这都是人生经验 对吧
所以你拍水面也是不是你上来你拍就拍好的
那你就去恋 拍不好怎么办 拍不好 总结就恋 哪没拍好 第二片再拍
第三片再拍 第三片再拍 第三片再拍 你走赢拍好的
对吧 那嘛一周是个气能的 怎么就学不会呢
所以个最痛苦的东西 不是说你不会
不是说你不会 而说我是可以学的 这个东西不就是个气能吗 你要阻动呢
你要阻动去学习啊 你老等别人推你 你怎么可能转到钱呢